нагадаю вашої
права означають і дзвонять і доль
передаєте верховній раді вище заради
правосуддям цінові рівні кіма і ніби
створені після організуйте ви цю роду з
цим закладаються основи для нових
суддівського корпусу засіки через
оперету статтю в тому експерти вказують
на корупціонер мови коли у судак може
зробити 10 самі любимо то дивимося н
пакети закону попитую процедуру та
осторонь нових судив він і формальну
перед та статей у судді з
конституційному суду кожному
гарантується право за датою константу
синус karhu до консультативних судом
теж соромно не простолюдини
закон можна буде і викликаних
неконституційним
судді за місцем нинішнього факти china
абсолютного імунітету буду так званою
функціональний імунітет судимо те-то
суддю на та потужні проти ноти до
кримінальної століттями дальності за його
юридичну позицію викладу на
судове рішення лавин системи
кримінальну то
дисциплінарними видалися розлучені то
провини ще судовим можна повиснути і
схуднення свого майна
звивини мене називаєш засудивши для
гарантій на особи сковується
поняття за значення судді на посаду
фаршем топ-топ років та річкові ви пробували
ний термін бо означають вир доль best
рукавом лише засудивши конституційного
судна та кіра нижчої визнають натиснути
рокки адвокатське представництва з
прийти до нього нитки вимкнено адвоката
тут не представляти свої ніші особливу
судимо атаку записує кримінальну
кабаново чинимо нині біля цивільного the hoes
подольську праворуч hand rss турин можете
представляти буде особливі ківи лякалася
а на 17 років